[Musique]
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver sur tv
soixante dix huit pour cette nouvelle
émission au cours de laquelle nous
allons vous donner idées conseils et
bons plans pour passer un été dans les
yvelines
et si vous êtes en recherche d'activités
insolites vous découvrirez alain bihr
entre géants de maïs du côté de jouars
pontchartrain
nous testerons également pour vous le
tir à l'arc à cheval tout aussi
inattendu assez rude nuit dans un
presbytère inutile de quitter le
département pour se dépayser dépaysement
toujours avec notre conseil resto la
chef babette de rozières nous fera
voyager aux antilles depuis elle son
établissement de maule les amateurs de
bons vins iront ensuite faire escale aux
côtés du côté du vignoble de la bouche
du roi c'est adav lé château méconnu les
expos en un mot câbles et les meilleurs
guinguette du département à suivre au
cours de ce set 8 loisirs les coups de
coeur des journalistes de la rédaction
[Musique]
et au cours de cette émission nous irons
également découvrir le nouveau parc de
loisirs urbains s my world à montigny le
bretonneux nous serons avec son
responsable dans quelques minutes pour
le moment c'est mélanie poquet que
j'accueille en plateau bonjour mélanie
bonjour nous vous allez nous donner des
bons plans pour connaître pleinement
profiter pleinement de ce département
des yvelines cet été ça fonctionne aussi
le reste de l'année d'ailleurs son nom
de ce mot de passe magique c'est le pass
malin un sésame qui vous permet
d'obtenir des réductions pour près de 80
sites et cela fonctionne aussi chez nos
voisins des hauts-de-seine oui le pass
malin où ils fritz et 15% de réduction
minimum à l'entrée des 80 sites
touristiques dans les deux départements
il est ouvert à tous sans condition de
domiciliation alors vous avez peut-être
vous le ferez de me demander comment
est-ce qu'il fonctionne je laisse ce
caroline qui pjanic chargé de la
promotion de la valorisation du
territoire du département des yvelines
nous l'expliqué cette impasse les
limites à réaliser il pu sauvegarder
notre téléphone en photo soit par e-mail
elle vous le présenter à l'accueil et
des 80 sites partenaires du dispositif
et vous avez droit à ce moment-là ins %
de réduction sur le droit d'entrée de
ces sites
le pass existe depuis trois ans et cette
année il ya des nouveautés il y en a
même deux lors des structures
culturelles ont rejoint le dispositif
comme le théâtre de châtillon celui de
bougival ou encore celui de sartrouville
le passe mal an évolue aussi des offres
ponctuelles sont maintenant proposés ce
sont les offres flash ça concerne des
événements comme les grandes eaux
musicales dans les jardins du château de
versailles ou encore le festival des
lumières du zoo de thoiry mais pas
seulement écoutés dans le cadre des
offres flash le départ lynn a créé cette
année l'offre du pass malin au jardin
qui consiste en toute la saison une
trentaine de visites des visites
exclusives dans les plus beaux jamais
et autour de sept lieux d'exception au
hameau de la reine au potager du roy à
la chaire nature et découvertes et à
notre domaine de madame elisabeth
domaine départemental des mineurs alors
si vous l'avez bien compris en me
touristes ou en mode habitants les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine ont tous leurs secrets
alors et à vous révéler merci beaucoup
mais la nuit en attendant maintenant que
vous connaissez se passe mal hein
pourquoi ne pas l'utiliser pour
découvrir les châteaux des yvelines il y
en a plus d'une dizaine certains
attirent moins de visiteurs que d'autres
et il ne manque pourtant pas de charme
ils offrent de superbes alternative à
versailles
voici notre top 3 des châteaux méconnu
dans le département
[Musique]
à
se perdre dans les entrailles d'un
labyrinthe géant telle alice la reine de
coeur en moins c'est ce que propose une
société implantée à travers la france et
depuis peu à jouars-pontchartrain petite
particularité supplémentaire les
labyrinthes sont créés grâce à des pieds
de maïs célia gars de son goût l'a testé
pour nous nous sommes le labyrinthe pop
corn de jouars-pontchartrain ici venez
vous perdre en famille ou entre amis sur
5 km de chemins moi je vais commencer le
parcours sur un champ de 4 hectares le
labyrinthe pop corn de
jouars-pontchartrain est ouvert tous les
jours de l'été
deux parcours sont proposés l'un réservé
aux plus de 7 ans avec plusieurs énigmes
à résoudre
l'autre accessible à partir de 4 ans les
familles peuvent faire le parcours en
bois avec les jeux en bois et donc ils
ont une feuille de poing au départ et à
chaque jeux en bois tout le monde
s'affrontent et on fait des équipes est
celui qui gagne le plus de points bas
gagnent ils gagnent le labyrinthe à la
fin cet après midi là de nombreuses
familles étaient présentes
pas simple parce que tout se ressemble
ça tourne beaucoup en rond on a beaucoup
de cul de sac quand on trouve une étape
avec un jeu on est plutôt on est plutôt
ravi en fait donc face à super moment
aux familles tout simplement c'est trop
et trop chouette comme comme contraire
il ya des énigmes il ya aussi des jeux
en bois des avec des palais avec des
jeux d'adressé et eon à lyon termine par
un mini labyrinthe avec d'autres énigmes
on doit chercher un petit code c'est
super on espère beaucoup mais l'essai
que s'amusant à la fin les plus petits
repartent avec un diplôme et les adultes
avec un cadeau il faut à peu près deux
heures pour faire le parcours un circuit
inédit le maïs sera récoltée comme un
chant normale en octobre et que l'année
prochaine on recommence et ça sera un
nouveau champ des nouveaux tracés des
nouveaux jeux et des nouveaux énigme
pour les plus gourmands un snack est
aussi mise à disposition il propose des
boissons des glaces et bien évidemment
du pop corn
[Musique]
si vous le souhaitez des nocturnes sont
également proposés tous les vendredis et
les samedis soirs de l'été avec une
lampe frontale vous pourrez parcourir
les différentes allées de maïs moi j'ai
pas encore fini le parcours justement
j'y vais et pendant que célia essaye de
sortir de ce labyrinthe restons dans le
domaine de la détente en famille avec le
centre smile world il vient d'ouvrir ses
portes au sein de l'espace 50 ans et à
montigny le bretonneux bonjour david
havas vous êtes son directeur oui tout à
fait bonjour monsieur ce my world c'est
un complexe qui propose bowling billard
lasergame karaoke il ya déjà eu des
centres de ce type à saint quentin et
dans les yvelines plus globalement
qu'est ce qui fait votre différence
votre force peut-être la différence
c'est qu'on est un groupe qui va
proposer différentes activités
on va voir différents endroits également
on a on a un site qui va ouvrir en
septembre sur bercy 2 et la force de
notre groupe c'est qu'on l'a différentes
structures et différentes activités
il ya une partie trampoline qui sera sur
bercy qui n'est pas encore sur montigny
mais voilà on est vraiment dans le
loisir urbain avec différents modèles
voilà il ya aussi des concerts qui vont
qui vont être organisés qui sont prévues
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr j'ai déjà un
gros concert qui arrive à la fin du mois
avec quelqu'un d'assez connu de suivi
sur les réseaux tic toc instagram je
peux pas dévoiler le nom pour l'instant
mais ça va venir
vous venez tout juste là d'ouvrir ce
début de mois de juillet la période avec
ce contexte sanitaire ne vous inquiète
pas est ce que le public a déjà répondu
présent écoutez le public a répondu
présent dans l'eau
big man dans un bowling la période de
juillet-août c'est vraiment la plus
calme de l'année
maintenant on a des super retour j'ai du
monde qui vient tous les jours je suis
largement au dessus de mon prévisionnel
donc si on est vraiment heureux et ça se
passe bien donc ce centre ce my world
qui est ouvert au sein de l'espace
commercial de saint quentin j'ai évoqué
rapidement votre offre bowling billard
lasergame j'ai oublié des choses
peut-être pouvait nourrir préciser
l'étendue de votre offre
oui oui on a une salle d'arcade le laser
game lui a plusieurs possibilités
on a le billard on a également quelque
chose de nouveau qui est vraiment sympa
qui cartonne très fort en ce moment sur
paris c'est des karaokés boxe voilà on a
plusieurs salles où les gens sont entre
eux chantent s'amuse danser y passe une
heure dans une dans une salle est
vraiment ils s'amusent personne ne les
dérange et personnes se moquent d'eux
quand ils chantent un voilà et les
karaokés boxe on en a trois ici sur
montigny et on en aura d'autres sur les
différents sites qui vont ouvrir
merci beaucoup david havas d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous présenter ce
complexe nouveau complexe à montigny le
bretonneux my world merci à patrick
jacques de dixmude et alex berrou qui
ont assuré la technique de ce duplex
depuis montigny donc passé à l'été dans
les yvelines c'est ce que nous vous
proposons avec ce 7 8 loisirs si le
temps n'est pas très clément vous pouvez
également vous rabattre sur les
expositions le top 3 des expos à ne pas
manquer dans le département c'est
maintenant et s'est préparé par justine
brasier
[Musique]
la laiterie de la reine et la salle de
bal de l'empereur ces deux espaces où on
essaie de recréer le monde antique
[Musique]
les offres qui ont toutes été
pratiquement pour l'essentiel commandé
par napoléon pour c'est sa propre
communication
[Musique]
c'est une histoire familiale que l'on
raconte dans cette exposition histoire
d'une dynastie de photographes français
[Musique]
les cinémas enfin ouvert rien ne vous
empêche pour autant de vous faire une
toile en plein air à la belle étoile
dans jour justine elle cet été dans le
département de nombreuses villes
proposent de redécouvrir des classiques
du septième art à saint quentin en
yvelines c'est le site de la commanderie
l encours qui centralise pour la
troisième année consécutive cette
opération exactement et donc pour cette
troisième édition l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines en partenariat
avec l'association contrechamp vous
donne rendez vous donc au parc de la
coulée verte qui est situé juste
derrière la commanderie elle les films
sont projetés à 22h les soirs de juillet
21h pour les soirs doux mais vous pouvez
vous rendre sur place dès 19 heures pour
pique vous profitez déjà des food
truck un moment convivial donc à
partager autour du 7e art huit films
sont à découvrir ou à redécouvrir des
films on aurait peut-être vu que sur
petit écran
et là on a quand même la possibilité de
les voir sur un écran de 16 mètres de
large et est aussi des films qu'on a
peut-être vu nous plus jeune et qu'on a
envie de faire découvrir aux enfants un
mot de la programmation de cette année
peut-être oui il y en a pour tous les
goûts film d'animation comédie thriller
aventure vous pourrez donc voir ou
revoir en plein air des films par
exemple de science fiction avec gravity
il y a aussi des classiques comme billy
elliot ou encore les goonies et puis des
films à suspense comme à couteaux tirés
par exemple qui est sorti en 2019
chaque membre de la famille avait un
mobile s carlane avaient prévu de couper
les vivres à johnny
est ce qu'il prévoyait deux virées
walter est ce que richard avait une
liaison
vos hypothèses sans oser génral renson
tu ne viens pas d'enterrement mais tu as
cours pour l'ouverture du testament dans
ton cas on devrait se voir comme souvent
[Musique]
est la nouveauté cette année wilfried
accueillir un film de miyazaki en plein
air ce qui était en fête interdite
jusqu'à maintenant
vous pourrez donc visionner le film
d'animation le château ambulant
ce sera le 5 août je le rappelle donc le
ciné plein air ça se passe tous les
jeudis soirs jusqu'au 20 6 ou les
séances sont gratuites avec entrée libre
dans la limite de la jauge bien sûr
autorisé la programmation sur le site de
la commanderie et pour moi ce sera les
goonies voilà merci justin j'ajoute que
de son côté le département propose
également la 10e édition des yvelines
font leur cinéma du 14 août au 10
septembre 45 séances proposées dans 45
communes
au programme opération corned beef à
versailles le corniaud à montain ville
ou encore les aventures de rabbi jacob
à porcheville justin est ce que vous
aimez l'équitation
bien sûr le tir à l'arc est également
oui j'en fais pas trop est ce que vous
connaissez le tir à l'arc à cheval c'est
astrid bergère qui est allé tester cette
pratique dans dans le département
histoire de se glisser dans la peau de
rebelles l'héroïne des studios pixar ont
parlé de cinéma justement regardez ce
reportage
aujourd'hui nous sommes au centre
équestre du moulin de la forge à
longvilliers nous allons tester le tir à
l'arc à cheval
c'est une activité ludique simple et
accessible à tous alors on n'avait que
jennifer vous êtes monitrice au centre
équestre du moulin de la forge
on va tester le tir à l'arc à cheval
qu'est ce que c'est le tir à l'arc à
cheval
alors du coup le tir à l'arc à cheval
c'est une discipline qui associée du
coup deux disciplines de tir à l'arc et
l'équitation est donc comment ça va se
passer là bas du conte à faire une
partie d'abord à pied et après bah du
coup on va se mettre à cheval on va
essayer au pas et si tout se passe bien
on enchaînera sur le gâteau très bien on
va tester ça donc c'est une discipline
qui se fait au pas et au galop parce que
le trop et pas assez stables et pas
assez régulier pour pouvoir tirer à
l'arc qui est très bien voilà allons-y
c'est parti c'est parti
[Musique]
il est aussi possible de tester le monte
entre une discipline qui se pratique à
l'aide d'éléments en bois
on travaille la décontraction du cheval
et du cavalier pour tester ses activités
il faut compter environ 50 euros la demi
journée
un stage est organisé le samedi 24
juillet pour découvrir le mountain créé
après toutes ces activités il faut aussi
profiter de l'été pour profiter du temps
qui passe au restaurant par exemple là
aussi le département regorge de
promesses depuis un maul c'est la chef
babette de rozières qui nous invite à
découvrir les saveurs antillaises beach
entebbe rien senti steban pour cette
mise en bouche
bienvenue à tv 78e fait plaisir de vous
recevoir ici alors venez je vais vous
faire visiter la casse de babette vous
avez la carte de la bête et toute une
histoire
ici c'était mon garage et j'avais vendu
tous mais resteront à jamais dit à mon
mari
il va falloir absolument que je monte
quelque chose il n'y ait pas d'accord et
du petit à petit vous avez comment sont
des femmes et les femmes n'arrête jamais
et jusqu'au jour où il m'a dit oui et
j'ai transformé ce garage en restaurant
et ça a donné ça
[Musique]
et puis on a la chance aussi d'avoir un
beau jardin
si vous voyez bien ce jardin il est un
peu conçues comme un jardin à
l'antillaise il ya des paillotes en
biologie les petits clients amoureux il
yad'autres paillote on met un petit
groupe
et puis vous avez toute l'étendue du
jardin où les gens passent du bon temps
avec le bout des oiseaux loin de paris
loin du bruit et des gus évidemment des
spécialités antillaises
parce que je suis foncièrement
guadeloupéennes dont je ne fais que les
spécialistes auxiette
venez vous faire goûter un plat vous
avez temps alors on va voter un plan
cuisine
alors je vous présente au mans qui est
mon second et qui est mon bras droit
quand je suis pas là c'est lui qui tient
la maison et il tient bien la maison ça
fait des années qu'il est là avec moi
alors on va faire un petit mois cet
espace repas pessah safrané et
maintenant tu peux être langue au sommet
allez on y va
la cruciale question d'amour en plus une
partie soit nous les chefs en cuisine
pour faire plaisir à l'autre
commencez par comme ça on sait pas ce
que le client va dire mais lorsque la
masia trop bien essuyer là on est
heureux en espagne n'est pas ce que nous
avons accompli notre tâche
alors bon appétit va garder après une
bonne table pourquoi ne pas s'offrir une
bonne bouteille avec modération bien sûr
mais du côté de d'avron se sont tout de
même six grands cépages français qui
sont proposés direction le domaine de la
bouche du roi avec michael almy drôle
visiter des vignes dans les yvelines cet
été c'est possible domaine de la bouche
du roa situe à d'avron dans la plaine de
versailles organise des circuits avec
dégustation des vins du mercredi au
dimanche
l'occasion de découvrir cette production
c'est insolite ça a été une très grande
région viticole avec plus de 40 mille
hectares de vignes au 19e siècle et
aujourd'hui grâce aux évolutions
climatiques on a pu replanter un
vignoble qui nous permet d'amener des
raisins à maturité ici et donc on
découvre dans un paysage très diversifié
un vignoble de 25 hectares d'un seul
tenant
donc c'est assez effectivement
originales et insolites de pouvoir
surtout ensuite goûté la typicité de
celles qui viennent d'arriver en
production depuis deux ans
cet été le domaine propose également un
circuit qui mêle visite dégustation de
vins et produits locaux appelés mets et
vins est proposée au tarif de 49 euros
on a derrière nous la table des
différents produits qu'on a choisi pour
aller avec nos vins donc on a
dès qu une cuvée qui va avec la truite
fumée de la pisciculture de ville est
qu'on commence à déguster avec un de nos
blancs on enchaîne ensuite avec une
bouchée de caviar d'aquitaine déguster
avec le chemin de la cuvée legrand levé
qu'on présente en 2d et ensuite on passe
au rouge avec un fromage de la ferme de
tremblay qui a un saint jacques à la
sauge très parfumé et on finit avec une
dernière cuvée en rouge et du chocolat
de la chocolaterie cola qui est une
entreprise voisine située à mol à la
rentrée d'autres activités insolites
seront proposées avec notamment des
cours de danse dans le domaine en
partenariat avec le cabaret le lido
les visiteurs pourront également
apprendre les travaux de la vigne en
septembre et en octobre pendant les
vendanges la structure espère recevoir
plusieurs centaines de personnes tout au
long de cette saison estivale les
guinguettes où avec cabaret populaire
reviennent à la mode et dont les
yvelines aussi il est possible d'aller
s'y amuser la nuit tombée voici une
sélection des meilleurs endroits
[Musique]
l'ambiance est vraiment sympa les gens
sont très très sympa ça fait vraiment
ambiance de vacances sa coupe un peu de
la vie du tumulte parisien
[Musique]
ce qu'on peut faire ici c'est en
véritable lieu de vie donc ce qu'on peut
faire ici c'est venir déjà entre amis en
famille ou même salle et c'est profiter
d'un bar d'un foot ruyt d'un espace s'il
est bien sûr d'une piste de danse qui
est maintenant si vous nous suivez
depuis le début de cette émission
j'espère que vous êtes convaincus de la
richesse du département pour passer un
été des paysans n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs
à laisser vos conseils dans les yvelines
de sortie sur nos réseaux sociaux avant
de refermer ses 7,8 loisirs nous allons
vous donner quelques conseils pour
passer une bonne nuit
astrid bonjour il est possible de
voyager de s'évader à quelques
kilomètres seulement de chez soi oui
proche de chez soi dans les yvelines il
est possible de passer une nuit dans un
lieu atypique au camping huttopia de
versailles par exemple plusieurs
logements originaux sont disponibles
comme la tante trappeur elle fait 25
mètres carrés et peut accueillir jusqu'à
5 personnes
c'est un solide parce que vous dormez
sous la tente et vous avez la vue sur la
forêt et puis vous êtes en pleine ville
c'est prête à accueillir ces des
facilités s'est aménagé vous dormez sous
tentes mais vous avez tout l'équipement
nécessaire à un petit séjour entre amis
ou en famille et dans ce même camping à
versailles il est aussi possible de
dormir dans une cahute une cabane ou
encore un chalet pour l'attendre a peur
il faut compter 3 110 euros pour 2 nuits
en haute saison
autre ambiance à présent hâte hivernale
gueugnon oui il est possible là-bas de
dormir dans un ancien presbytère du
xviie siècle
l'hébergement est collé à l'église
gothique du village c'est une maison
d'hôtes
il ya deux chambres et un appartement
une cuisine un espace de vie sont
accessibles à tout le monde comme le
jacuzzi
est-ce qu'on a des activités à proximité
il ya bien sûr le château de versailles
ou encore le zoo de thoiry
mais on peut aussi se balader dans la
commune à cinq minutes à pied il ya par
exemple un ancien de l'avoir à découvrir
et pour le g au presbytère de thiverval
grignon il faut compter entre 110 euros
et 200 euros la nuit en fonction du
logement merci
coût astrid pour toutes ces bonnes
adresses c'est la fin de notre rendez
vous les programmes se poursuivre sur tv
à 78 tout au long de l'été j'en profite
néanmoins pour remercier toutes les
équipes de leur implication tout au long
de l'année avec une pensée particulière
pour vous astrid et pour eléonore
également après une année passée au sein
de la rédaction
vous partez vers de nouveaux horizons
merci à vous encore c'est la fin donc de
cette émission on se retrouve en
septembre pour de nouveaux programmes
n'oubliez pas que l'information se
poursuit sur tv 78 tout au long de l'été
prenez soin toujours de vous et des
autres à bientôt
[Musique]